je vais vous répondre je suis du côté
des commerçants à 100 % mais pas comme
ça et votre colère vous aveugle c'est ça
le problème et en faisant ça vous créez
deux problèmes majeurs plus vous êtes
hors la loi donc vous êtes
potentiellement délinquant puisque vous
un an de prison vous diffusez des images
sans autorisation quel quoi qu'on pense
des voleurs ignobles mais vous les
diffusez et deuxièmement là j'ai parlé à
des policiers vous cassez il te parl les
policiers après ce que tu dis sur eux te
parl les policiers
est-ce que je dis du mal des
policiers tu veux les désarmer policier
s toi tu veux que les policiers battent
avec
frag policiers
parore les policiers sont bien
gtil j'ai beaucoup de contact pari les
poliers tu avo non ça c et vous cassez
le travail vous cassez le travail pourav
je vais vous expliquer pourquoi il voir
c'est pas eux qui cassent le travail non
mais c'est pas eux qui cassent le
travail c'est la justice derrière non
parce que cyil quand j' peux plus parle
parle à Jérôme bon Jérôme et Monsieur
quand on diffuse des images ok de
voleurs si ces voleurs sont retrouvés si
la police il rend fou disent les gens si
la police les interpelle la procédure va
être annulée à cause de la diffusion
d'imag mais bien sûr que oui c'est la
loi c'est la loi C c'est la loi
fa pas tu fatig s'il te plaît pas
disimpor disorteoi écoute qu' va dire
parce que tu dis enc tu
disc arr de monter suressayer de jacard
ce qui est bien plus au cour to est-ce
que tu peux lui dire est-ce que tu peux
lui dire chemisors
auxtats-unis
passunisi laisse
par autatsunis un principe qui s'appelle
le name and c'est utilisé par c'est
exactement le même système c'est
exactement ce qu'il demande c'est
utilisé par la justice il s'agit en fait
de montrer quels sont les auteurs d'un
d'un d'un acte d'un et de leur de leur
mettre la honte c'est comme c'est c'est
comme ça et le procédé a été repris par
le gouvernement français dans certains
cas je te signale que les entreprises
qui notamment pratique de la
discrimination des entreprises peuvent
les dénoncer de la même faç
tu vas sur les Sit aujourd'hui je suis
all regarder le il est utilisé je suis
en train de te dire que le principe
estutiliséout le principe légal a été
utilisé par le gouvernement
fr par la DGCCRF lorsqu'il y a des
entreprises qui doivent
être dénoncé dans des cas de de vol
d'argent ou dans des cas de
discrimination je vois pas pourquoi dans
ces CASL ce serait pas utilisé donc ton
argument de
dire est Mo en temp
r diff n'orte
quoiinruction
qui suffisait diffuser des images pour
que les procédures so annul tous les
F pour
pas les avocats des interpellés font
jouer la diffusion des images pour annul
leséu mon vu ça arrête un
peu un système de défense utilisé par
lesurs par les avocats qu'on doit
s'arrêter
dire é
pourner me
mebatementb
comment des bêtis jérô est changer la
loi pour l'instant c'est comme ça en
fait les gars j parle parle à alors
changer la loi on est tous très très
ambitieux ce soir mais ça va être
compliqué dans le code pénal c'est ce
que la police dit souvent ce qu'il faut
que vous sachiez c'est que bien souvent
on a une commerçante dans l'Allier voyez
elle a diffusé les images des voleuses
elle est courageuse elle est dans une
parfumerie dans l'Allier trois voleuses
sont arrivé la mère et ces deux filles
ça commence bien en terme d'éducation
sont partis avec 800 € de parfum elle a
diffusé comme je que va leur dire vous
sentez
bon c'est intéressant elle a diffusé
elle a diffuser les images des voleuses
en disant voilà c'est pas normal
ramenez-moi ce que vous m'avez volé elle
a porté plainte elle a reçu un courrier
d'avocat voilà qui lui disait bonjour
madame madame machin madame machin
madame machin donc comme ça l'identité
des trois voleuses c'est l'avantage vous
demande de retirer rapidement les images
sinon elle portera ple culot c'est ce
qui vous explique sais ou oui mais fin a
nom des personnes va se retourner
contreid identités des voleurs et bien
évidemment que ça fait plus de de mois
qu'il n'ont pas porté
plainteur pas qu' V porter plain c'est
de l'intimidation et toi tu rentres
danses conneries rent pas dans juste
question est-ce que par ailleurs vous
n'avez pas pas peur justement que ça se
retourne et non pas de façon juridique
parce que là ils ont été gentil ils ils
sont venus avec un avocat avec un petit
courer mais qui viennent faire le coup
de se venger un risque de ça aussi de
peur à ce tu fais plus rien exactement
ils sont tellement à bout ils sont
tellement abandonnés qu'en fait ils ont
on m pas pe alors ça peut peutêtretant-i
g Verz mais la peur do changer de camp
moi j'ai une question à vous poser vous
permettez tous les soirs vous AZ des
questions à poser
question mais si on fait rien on les met
dans un certain confort bah oui qui fait
que ça ne s'arrêtera jamais donc quelle
est la solution faut serrer les C ne
rien faire et
et être vigilant mais ça paye pas
attends attends il une question à me
poser s'il te plaît oui vous êtes un
animateur regardé par des millions de
personnes l'article
221 Pardonce qu'il veut ben vous posez
une question si vous le permettez
allez-y avec ton article vas-y l'article
221 du code pénal donc puni d'un an de
prison et de 45000 € d'amende les gens
qui diffusent des images de vidéo
protection vous êtes donc pour entrer
dans l'illégalité en disant que vous
comprenez
non es tu vois bien que la loi elle est
la loi la loi la loi la loi la lo la
lo ce que tu es ce que tu es es je le
redis tu es le symbole de l'échec jure
tu sais quoi la France si elle est dans
l'état dans lequel elle est aujourd'hui
c'est à cause de gens comme toi tu veux
que je te dises tu symbolises l'échec de
la France aujourd'hui c'est des gens
comme toi non mais c'est des gens comme
lui c'est des gens comme lui qui font
que la France on est où elle en est
aujourd'hui des gens mais comme lui qui
ne veulent rien changer qui sont dans
qui qui sont tu sais quoi qui qui qui
privilégieent toujours la délinquance si
si je te
dis non pas la loi pas la loi tu sais
quoi tu sais quoi si tu sais quoi tu es
tu es le symbole de l'échec français si
un jour j'écris un livre qui s'appelle
l'échec français je mettrai ta gueule
dessus est-ce que vous conenez c c histo
sur le
glette histoire- qu'il a dit la Verue
gland
[Applaudissements]
age mais vous rendez compte dans le
monde de Gill en fait des des femmes qui
venaent de voler dans une parfumerie
veulent porter plainte contre la
parfumeuse voilà où on en est donc moi
je suis je suis en la loi et je suis
fierre de l'être dans ce cas je lance
une nouvelle séquence demain le monde de
Gill je
jure s tell protégés qu'en fait il
maintenant les voleurs vont porter
plainte c'est comme
on non mais 2 minutes mchman oui
contrairement à ce que vous venez de
dire la majorité des commerçants qui
l'ont fait ont eu sans les caméras sans
les micros les encouragements de la
police vous êtes en décalage avec la
réalité monsieur
ver le faites très bien je peux vous
assurer que tous les commerçants qui
vous regardent ce soir ouais ils sont en
colère tu sais quoi va pas chez
commerant j'en connais plein des
commerçants je passe je passe ma vie à
faire les cours chez les commerçants
mais je les comend tout à fait mais pas
pas la
méthode vous voulez qu'il fasse quoi il
se passe rien monsieur ver confi
à la vidéo surveillance il
mant
ch parce que là ce qui me gêne chez vous
c'est que vous remettez en question la
qualité le travail des
policiers ce que tu fais là tu sais ce
que tu fais là c'est horrible ce que tu
es de faire c'est comme ce que tu viens
de faire y a 2 secondes quand tu dis
vous tes dans é égalité hors la loi tu
sais quoi tu es vraiment un petit
hypocrite ouais je vais te dire la
vérité parce que là tu sais ce que tu es
en train de faire là tu es en train de
lui mettre tu es en train de le mettre
en porte à faux par rapport à la police
et ça c'est très grave ce que tu es en
train de faire je trouve ça nul ce que
tu en c'est pas du tout ce qu'il a dit
donc tu tu encore tu tu sais quoi tu
transformes ce qu'a dit monsieurum tu
transformes a dit Monsieur Jean et c'est
extrêmement grave parce que qu'est-ce
qu'il fait demain il va aller porter
plin à la police on va retenir ce qu' a
dit g merd tu dis n'importe qui c'est
pas du tout ce qu'il a dit a dit que la
police faisait très bien son travail
sauf que derrière comme tout le monde le
dit c'est que un moment derrière ça
r00
jreemout il vont dire gars c'est bon on
va rester à la mais rester avec notre
famille on va arrêter de prendre r voilà
donc g ver excuse-moi mon g t'aime
beaucoup mais tu
es y a quelques années je me souviens
dans cette émission ça m'avait frappé tu
étais contre la vidéo surveillance dans
les res généralisé ou voilà parce
libertide encore une FO ça c'est
dramatique parce que grâce à la vidé
surveillance aujourd'hui on arrête des
pédmin on arrêé par surveill V dans dans
des quartiers compliqués des accidents
de voiture et tu vois ça par exemple
typiquement et ben là c'est une erreur
gravissime de ta part vous Remz le
travail de la police en
question vous Remz en question le
travail de la
police que tous les jours il s'ppu sur
la
vidéo je suis pas contre la vidéo
surveillance dans les établissements
établissement s vidé
surveillance avoir une on sait pourquoi
tu es arrête un peu on sa pouroi
tu on a dans la vie on t'adore sur le
plateau toutes tes idées sont des idées
des années 80 et des idées qui ont été
faites et refaites et refaites et refait
qui font qu'aujourd'hui la France est
dans l'état dans lequel elle est c'est
tout si on a les gars en fait tu tu sa
quoi tu es très bien représenté par tous
ceux qui ont été au pouvoir jusqu'à
présent en tu veux que je dises en
vérité tu tu as toujours gagné parce que
tu as toujours été dans l'échec et en
fait tu vois vraiment tu tu symbolises
tu tu vraiment le symbole de l'échec
français et continue hein mais tu verras
qu'à un moment ça va bouger et je te dis
tu es complètement désacord tu sais quoi
tu es hors cadre tu es à côté de la
plaque à côté de la plaque ou cé jeis
qu'on voit le sondage une fois de plus
pour mettre une claque à verd voilà
merci 96%
4.4 la France de Gill ver on a le Paris
d' maintenant on va voir la France de
Gill Verz merci 44 gens pas compris la
question mais 44 c'est la famille et
c'est le seul policier qui connaît qui a
la retraite depuis 25 ans merci à vous
merci d'avoir été là et on pense à la
pétition on espère qu'elle va bien
monter et vous revenez nous voir quand
vous voulez dès que vous avez un souci
ou si vous avez un message à faire
passer vous êtes toujours les bienvenus
on pense au commerçants pour qui c'est
extrêmement dur et qui doit en plus
gérer ces conneries de de mecs qui
pensent qu' a une chose c'est aller dans
les magasins pour voler et faire des des
stratagèmes voilà donc je vous dis bah
Verdez c'est gentil de faire cette tête
là
merci lui lui il met le feu il fait ah
bah merde merci ça brûle allez à tout de
suite